my job now is to find you a good partner
that's what i'm going to do so you have
to tell me what you're looking for okay
employed okay uh nice okay handsome
tall i guess they don't have to be tall
why tall i just i like the feeling of
someone like uh give me a height
enveloping because people are listening
right now and you know what we have a
lot of people listen to this podcast
this is a good chance to get this
message out give me a height uh
give me a height minimum for you minimum
i think i'm really tall so i'm gonna say
six two okay maximum
six five
anything bigger
that's scary wait how tall are you i'm
six four okay great you're not scary no
but if they if the hair is puffed up six
five six six six seven so yeah um no but
i'm six four so
i i would still slide in under the bar
okay well probably not for other reasons
but um we'll get we'll talk about those
later
uh impotence um okay
uh old war injury um
so six two what else about this fellow
let's see employed nice attractive
we have to have things in common
oh a good sense of humor right likes to
he he
um
uh-huh because i didn't understand what
you meant by good sense of humor so i'm
glad you said likes
you know i'm just trying to clarify yeah
um
big hands i like big hands because i
have big hands
uh that's a strange one i have to say i
like big hands yeah i like big hands
have you ever sometimes i've been
hanging around with someone it's not
something you think you notice right
away but then eventually you look down
you'll be talking to a guy and then
you'll see that his hands are just so
tiny so tiny yeah and it's a little i
know what you mean you think they're up
to something it's a little jarring you
ever see a scary movie too
a long time ago yeah oh and he's like
get my good hand it's just a tiny hand i
don't want i don't
want tiny hands like big meaty hands
okay what if a guy tricked you and wore
like uh fake gloves or got a bunch of
bee stings
okay we've got a bunch of these things
we just had
but they tricked you they tricked you
because they heard this and they checked
every box and they said i can't wait now
to to date and become the long term
boyfriend for nicole byer and then they
reached over to shut off the app that
had the podcast on it and looked down at
their hand and it was this tiny little
hand
and they tricked you i guess if they
went through the trouble of getting a
realistic prosthetic hand to make it
seem like a bigger hand
i think i could forgive it you'd be like
wow you really did something nice right
and then in the end you realize i didn't
care about that all along yeah
you realize yeah exactly
and then i'll be like i'm shallow and
then i go through a journey and they've
taught me so much and it's great
so that's
that's my love story
[Laughter]
should their hands have to be big enough
to honk my titties i was just thinking
that if they're too tiny you'll get more
oh my god get your prosthetic hand out
[Music]
and that's me coming
do you ever say that as your orgasm and
that's me coming it'd be fantastic to
announce that
that's really funny you should look to a
camera you should have a camera there
you can look to the camera
and that's me that's me coming
and then little credits come up
produced by directed by conan are you
putting me in a porn well
yes i don't think i could do a porn you
don't think so i don't think so just
because i'd be like worried about my
performance and the angles
that's about it
so the whole
all the other questions that might come
up
wouldn't bother you at all what's this
doing for my psyche
all that kind of stuff no
i think that's all fine okay i'm just
like the angles like do we have them all
right and then also it's like
you've shot like scripted [ __ ] you get
it from like different angles like a
wide amid a close-up like yeah yeah do
they do that in porn well first of all
the times i've been involved in porn or
even contemplated it i've always
insisted on director's cut i want to be
able to sign off on the final product
and say i'm not happy with this shot i'm
not happy with that shot uh many of my
comments about my work my complaints
have been about my actual body so like
we've done uh cgi and stuff like that
we've enhanced everything
and we've come up with a very different
product in the end but if you ask for
control uh-huh you'll be quite happy
okay
i feel like you're doing a bit but
i think that's good advice
to have more control i love the first
second
you thought i was actually
really contemplating doing a problem i
don't know maybe i've thought about it i
don't know but i don't know if it's good
money uh i'm just gonna i don't know i
don't think it would be good you're
looking at me
we both looked at you and it is trust me
yeah it's great money is it oh no it
can't be unless you're his name i think
you have to be a name how do you become
a name in porn well you're already a
name so you could just go into porn and
then you've done it you know what i mean
you you go you like reverse engineer it
i'm gonna say i don't know i first of
all i don't think the money would be
that great me either i really don't
think so
what about softcore like skinamax porn
does that still exist it should
you know um
i'm sure it does
where things get off what are you
looking at where there's like everything
it's all foggy yeah it's like filming
through vaseline or like pantyhose on
the lens and not because of a cinematic
technique
it just was random that there was a
pantyhose just got through and they said
keep rolling yeah uh no i think these
are all bad ideas okay i think these are
all bad ideas i think the important
thing that you should stick to
is i like this mission that you have to
find a real person to be with
who's going to be your partner your
confidant your your best bud that's what
you want yeah yeah i think that's good
yeah whenever a couple is like that's my
best friend i'm like ooh that seems nice
a best friend that you get to [ __ ]
that's like
a double-double i've had a hard time
finding that hallmark card
where's the best friend i like to [ __ ]
cards
uh
well that's the only thing is i mean
over the years and when you've been
talking to me you've been quite vocal
about physical attributes you're looking
for a guy and sexual needs and things
like that and so that might be
intimidating there might be some guys
out there i would like a big dick
i know but i can't believe i forgot that
yeah but you don't stop maybe
intimidating to some guys who feel they
don't measure up in that department okay
and then there then they think well i
can't and maybe there's a guy who
is just sort of normal average
and he now thinks and he'd be a
fantastic partner for you okay but he
now feels that that's not possible i'll
revise it um i would like a dick that's
uh nice
what do you mean like a nice like kind
uh yes a kind giving dick it does
volunteer work
does volunteer work yeah it feeds hungry
children it ties it ties it gives up 10
of its income to charities i like a
tithing dick
it gives to the it just gives it a very
good very good service
yeah yeah exactly no just like nice to
look at yeah handsome dick you want a
handstand a handsome one yeah or someone
who knows how to use it or we could just
go get another one if you could get a
little dildo or something oh i thought
you might have a transplant no okay
i don't think they do that
they don't because you can't get like
who's donating their dick they do not
trust me trust me
trust me they do not
and it's a crime
maybe one day in the future the richest
country in the world with the most
sophisticated
and you'd think
that people would put a little bit of
effort they'll put one right next to it
but they won't swap it out
i have seven different sizes
like a pan flute yes
it's a fan flute basically
you can play all kinds of complicated
songs on it